slash ability
to listen engage
others moods
having high emotional
intelligence eq
being a jedi
in social relationships
being able to navigate that space
frictionlessly harmonically
to the degree where people talk
about how well
you navigate the space
how you know to be polite
how you know to ask the right questions
how you know
to give the right non-verbal
cues that then show people
that you're genuinely authentically
listening to them and caring about them
how you know to prioritize
that
nunchi this
subtle art with social dynamics
in a way that drives you and your
success
further
you achieve more in your family dynamics
you achieve more in your friendships you
achieve more in the business and
entrepreneurial world
in your spirituality
because you've prioritized eq this
emotional intelligence this nunchi
the korean nunchi comes from
approximately the 1600s
chinese i force slash
power literally i
measure so this
i force i power i measure
is how well you handle the subtle art of
social relationships
high social sensitivity to maintain
harmony when somebody
has the anger
emotion do you know how to be a
jedi and peacefully and gracefully and
wisely with your
happiness and with your peace
that's imperturbable and your joy that
is causeless
do you know how to navigate that so that
the other person
also notches down their anger towards a
more peaceful and happy and joy-filled
state
do you know how to navigate those
stressful situations
a lot of this work with emotional
intelligence has to do with
spiritual quotient sq as well
because the more that you
undergo the process that the buddha
talked about
where you dive down
inward to the roots of your
craving and aversion and you
eradicate the clinging
and the aversion to either
what you want and desire or what you
don't want and don't desire
and rather you
are able to maintain a level of
equanimity of
peace and of joy in
every single cloud that arises as an
experience you recognize that you're the
sky
rather than getting lost in the cloud of
experience
that's what enables you to have high
nunchi
the spiritual quotient is what drives
the emotional
quotient but also having lots
of combinations of social experiences
when you go through the permutations
when you go through these
example after example you pick up all of
the
myriad algorithms that happen
in social scenarios and you figure out
how to navigate them more and more like
a jedi
more and more swiftly but if you
yourself
are going to get triggered because you
haven't went on the inward path
then it'll be difficult for you to
navigate the eq
so the sq the spiritual quotient is
going to enable you to navigate
external eq social relationships a lot
more
fluidly harmonically
and this is paramount for your
interpersonal dynamics across
all of your relationships again family
how often is it that we butt
heads with our family but those with
high nunchi
are able to be very subtle
and very graceful very agile
with their ability to be
wise and be graceful they know
when to not engage
how many people can say that they know
when to not engage
everybody's always trying to prove
themselves
and that's why lautza wrote in the
doubted qing
that the wise man doesn't have to prove
himself
know when to take a step back be subtle
be like a jedi to that degree with your
friends as well
when your friends have something come up
in their life
do you know how to honestly genuinely
authentically give a [ __ ] about them
do you know how to pick up the phone and
call them
and say i'm here for you right now
do you know how to help them when they
need help
do you know how to just hold space for
them when they need somebody to listen
to them
do you know how to motivate them when
they need the motivation
when they need the accountability
and especially having nunchi with your
friends that are of the opposite sex
as well because what's gonna happen is
men especially the ones that have
high emotional intelligence the ones
that are like
jedi's they're going to recognize more
and more
that their relationships with women
are because women find them to be a good
friend
and for men that are awakened for men
that are enlightened
their relationship with women is not
prioritized
by their biological desire to reproduce
with them
it's prioritized as a co-creative
capacity
to actualize unique projects and gifts
into the world to help them achieve
what's in their heart
to help them both god realize going
inward and
actualize going outward
and that's the same thing with women and
men as well for them to be able to
navigate their relationships
with their guy friends as well
in a way that has a high subtlety
a high ability to navigate
the god realization and the
actualization
as the priority over the biological
primal instinct
that's not to say it won't happen at any
point of course
there's still procreation and
reproduction
that's very necessary those are very
necessary for us to continue
creating these portals for the next
humans to come through
and play in this dream
yet with friends
it's gonna be really important for you
to recognize
how to do that with the opposite sex and
then with business
as well with business there's going to
be
a lot of times when you have to know
how to negotiate your worth
if you're negotiating an hourly pay
where a lot of people are at today then
negotiate on your behalf but really be
working hard in order to know how to
step into that conversation with the
boss
and do that process same thing with a
partner if you're in an llc and you have
an equity split
in the company or maybe you're an
employee and you're getting
a point one percent vested over four
years at your company
maybe you think you deserve two percent
after the first year
because you've performed well and so you
want that
over the next three years in increasing
amounts
to earn two percent at the end instead
of one after four years
so in order for
you to be able to navigate those
situations swiftly
you have to have the jedi like nunchi
to recognize
the social dynamics between you
and your partner and your llc or
negotiating with or with your boss
at the company that you're earning
equity for or the hourly wage
that you're requesting to be increased
by your boss
and so there's all of these dynamics in
the business world with negotiations as
well to know
at a deeper level with social
relationships and social dynamics
and that's why there's this abundance or
absence
of nunchi so you can put it on a big
spectrum
where you have the
here we have the example of the nunchita
the quick-witted the understand
situations quickly
common sense another way to say it is
nunchi
paruda quick nunchi
and then on the other side of the
spectrum over here we have nunchi
ipta clueless no common sense
lacking nunchi so you have this quick
weighted quick nunchi side and you have
this clueless
lacking nunchi side and so
to recognize where you're at in your
abilities
on that spectrum of jedi like ability to
navigate
interpersonal dynamics
there are so many people that are super
hardcore
on the iq and they don't have any eq
and there are people that have tons and
tons of sq
and spiritual quotient and god
realization but they have absolutely no
iq and they have little eq
in little dq digital quotient
very few people are able to swiftly
navigate the space of all four of those
nunchi the eq component is
massively critical and in modernity dq
the digital quotient your ability to
disseminate
memes the mimetics the units of cultural
information transfer
to be able to disseminate those around
the world in distilled and exciting
artistic ways
that inspire people
is a huge underappreciated combination
in modernity
and so is the god rely state in the
spiritual quotient
so more and more it's becoming clear
that your polymethy
being a polymath having learned much
across different disciplines
your breadth is really
important and the eq the nunchi the
social interpersonal dynamic
space with your family your friends your
co-workers people online
is insanely important for both
your moment to moment as well as
for your successes
in life
that online component is another one
because the social dynamics are
important in person
but we don't talk about the social
dynamics online
enough here's the thing if you're god
realized
you actually recognize that the quote
other
is actually the self or god
expressing itself through
us as unique expressions of that
one infinite and so
because of that you would never write
something negative to somebody else
it doesn't even make sense you would
never dislike
what somebody says
and here's the reason why because you
would know how to
jedi navigate the scenario where if you
are going to engage you're going to say
something like
somebody just made a comment on one of
our recent videos i believe
julie did and said that
this additional camera that we had in
the background
that it was
taking away from the cleanliness
of the background shot here and so for
the next couple of streams before we
have another guest come on the show
where i need that camera back for
if we take visual notes i've moved it to
the side
and the person when they commented they
made it really clear
that hey great video here's just a piece
of feedback
and i hope you take it to consideration
and i did take it to consideration
because it was done as a jedi it was
done with high noon she
and that's when you know because it's
the god realized state speaking to the
god rely state
which is that you and i are the same
god we are the same one infinite
expressing itself
through these unique expressions and
talking to itself
and so that spiritual quotient enables a
lot of emotional quotient to become
really successful
and think of yourself on the spectrum
from having an abundance of nunchi to
having an
absence of nunchi and practicing because
as an
interviewer especially over 720 of these
interviews in the last couple of years
i've went through the combinatorics the
permutations of sitting down for these
one-on-ones
with our guests and looking at them in
the eyes
and recognizing all of the unique
expressions
all the unique aromas that they are
in the way that they hit these tennis
balls over to me and my ability to
with high emotional intelligence hit
them back
and the same thing's true with your
family with your co-workers with your
friends with people online
the same thing's true across those
dynamics is
knowing how to swiftly navigate them and
that's why this word here
meta communication you have to go beyond
communication
you have to have this macro level view
on communication
so you're not just excuse me
so you're not just in the cloud
of the experience but you're also taking
the observation or the witness
perspective from the macro level and
watching
what's happening from that sky watching
the clouds
and so that way you're become meta
aware aware of awareness
aware of communication aware of the
nuances of the social dynamics of what's
happening
and therefore you can look and recognize
things like
para language so you can recognize
things like these non-verbal and
non-lexical cues
for emotion and meaning and that's going
to be things like the intonation
the pitch the speed hesitation
gasp sigh moan groan throat clear
vocalix
and that's also going to be things like
gesticulation
with the facial and body expressions the
eye rolls the eyebrow raises
jaw drops arms crossed intense versus
arms relaxed and leaned back
and you have to know all of those
dynamics depending on the other person
that you're speaking to
based on their status and clout which
makes it really
more difficult it adds another variable
so
and this is a lot different in example
the korean and the japanese
chinese cultures than it is in the
united states when you're
potentially talking to somebody that is
maybe a young
artist or influencer or musician
it's a lot different talking to them
especially if they're millennial or gen
z
than it is when you talk to somebody
that was
born in the 50s or the 60s and that
is well known
and that has a different level
of social dynamics that need to be
applied if you
see the difference between that you're
already really aware
that's a whole level somebody born in
the 1960s
is today like 60 years old and somebody
born
in the 1990s is today like 30 years old
and so you recognize how to navigate the
difference between someone that's 60
years old and someone that's 30 years
old
and if you recognize even that and how
you dynamically
adjust yourself to not only their age
but also their status
as well because again you're gonna
be able to achieve a lot more with
people if you
are cool and calm and relaxed
in the sense of it's important to be
excited
and it's important to mirror people's
excitement and their levels
of expression but yet it's also
important to recognize that the first
impression is so
damn important and that
if you are calm and collected
and surgical and precise with your
words and with your nonverbal cues
with your para language
you're going to be able to achieve a lot
more in these interpersonal dynamics off
of the bat
because people are going to recognize
that about you
and that's why today you can see this
list of emojis that we
have here emojis are another sort of way
to understand this
type of non-verbal or non-lexical cues
for meaning
and emotion because
you have these emotion icons where you
have a
smiley face or a winky face or the kissy
face
or the heart or the pr or the prayer
and that these all mean different things
and that
then there's also an interpretation a
hermeneutics
that happens on the person that receives
it
as well and so
noon she also has a lot to do with your
ability to use
emojis it has a lot to do with your
ability to navigate the digital quotient
landscape do you know how to write
really solid captions do you know how to
write really solid
bios do you know
how to be swift with
using a couple words in a message or
maybe you just
send over a quick audio message back or
maybe you send over a video message back
maybe you call and do a facetime
right away a video call so that you can
jump right into what you need to
discuss with the person
having this style of analysis
on a meta communicative level it
makes you more like a jedi
but you got to know that these things
exist let's go over these examples here
you have the intonations and the pitches
and then you have the speed at which you
talk
the speed at which you talk
and then you have whether or not people
hesitate and then you have the
uh
and what those do is they
especially when people are speaking to
you and you're locked in
eye contact wise that
you can deliver back
a verification
on an emotional intelligence level to
them that makes
them feel like you're registering
at a deep level so when somebody
finishes
a profound sentence
maybe they say something like they're
grateful that they did not get hurt from
the car accident they were just
in and you say something like
and you have that gasp you have that
that jaw drop look at the eyebrows right
the jaw has dropped the eyebrows are up
and now look at the difference if you
don't do that
and you're just looking at them and they
say that
they're grateful that they didn't get
hurt during the car accident you're like
wow
there are so many nuances in meta
communication to be able to
properly
show people that you have high nunchi
and that has a lot to do with
gesticulation as well you can tell that
i use a lot of gesticulation when i talk
and there's a huge difference between
when you
kind of like sit back
versus when you come forward and versus
when you kind of go
huge differences huge differences
the vast majority of the time you want
to be engaged
that's as simple as it is engaged in the
sense of
if it's relaxing this type of an
engagement is good
the arms crossed engagement is a very
closed off engagement
and the leaned in style engagement
is especially important for body
movement if you want to like gesticulate
and also if you want to kind of be a
little bit potentially quicker witted
as well you're leaning
in or you're leaning back
but you're not really going like this
you really don't want to be tense that's
a
thing to avoid is being tense don't
lock your jaw
be very careful to not be fidgeting
don't be like fidgeting with something
non-stop
watch out for your knees when you're
doing the thing where you're
when you're doing the leg tapping
don't be anxious take a deep breath
relax and then recognize that
that's another expression of infinity
you're an expression of infinity as well
you're just infinity talking to itself
you are god
talking to itself
through these expressions
and to recognize that you relax
it becomes more playful it becomes more
harmonious
it becomes more love driven more wise
it's not about taking something from
myself
and then having the other person be less
well-off
it's about the rising tide lifting all
the boats
it's about the pie growing and becoming
bigger for everybody to share
in essence the really strong word to use
for nunchi
is sensing
in a sense you are like a
cell you're like a cell
that has to sense its environment
and you have to know about the
communication that's happening
intercellularly between cells
and all of the different social dynamics
that happen
at that intercellular level and so
you as a cell are constantly sensing so
some people's
sensing nunchi emotional quotient
abilities
they might be absent
versus they might be abundant you want
to be closer to the abundant
side of sensing
and you want to be more on the abundant
side of being able to navigate like a
jedi
and to know when to engage to know when
to
not to remain
equanimous peaceful loving joyful
harmonious yet know when to
extract yourself from a scenario
knowing how to provide the right cue at
the right time
in all of your social relationships
across family
friends co-workers people online and
that's why
on a sensing level it's really about the
other cell
it's about sensing their mood their
current feelings their state of mind
it's also about nunchi sensing
ambiguities
so you're going to have people that have
this gray area
and one person that does not have noon
sheet is going to have no idea how to
react to that
and another person that has nunchi is
going to be like joseph in the code of
many colors
and is going to be able to whip out
anything off of their tool belt because
they have a lot of
breadth when you have a lot of breadth
in social experiences and you have a lot
of tools available to you
it's really easy for you to navigate
the emotional intelligence landscape
even in those gray areas
especially humor you know how to use
humor you know how to play
with people and when you know how to do
all these different types of things
when you know how to do that and then
you know how to get
a little bit serious and uh what was the
equity stake that you were offering
right there
if you know how to do both of those
things if you can ed between
the absolutely silly
and the um let them know that we want a
more ethical supply chain
if you can do those two things you have
mastered life because
that is in a sense the god realized
state which is the very playful
state the very child-like laughter of
the infinite state
and then you have the god actualization
the outward
expression which is very much like the
business and the entrepreneurship
and the success of the expression
of the infinite
and another good example with sensing
is podcasts versus vodkas
because when you take the
audio only component which
if you take one of these that
is across some of the audio
distributions that we have
and you don't have the video component
of it you're going to have
a lower resolution
emotional intelligence to draw from and
analyze
sensing wise when you have the video
component you have a higher resolution
sensing that you can do about the
mood and the emotional state of the cell
that you're
dealing with or that is expressing
itself
and so you can really see where these
ambiguities these interpretations
come into play where
if it's just on audio
it's a lot more difficult for you to be
able to interpret sometimes
especially if somebody is speaking like
a monologue
and they're
keeping pretty much the same tone
and pitch throughout
your dynamicism your ability to go
all the way up really really high
and then go really really low
and to be able to do that and to be able
to do that whole play
and business that navigation is so
critical and you always gain points by
trying to understand eq
versus when you tell the one that's
trying to teach you something to [ __ ]
off
because when you take
the wisdoms that are being communicated
to you like i gave you that example a
moment ago with the camera
or when i gave you the the other
examples with
people that are like a mentor
to somebody when they're
helping them with some of their
entrepreneurship
or some of the actualization of their
gifts or some of their god realization
process
to not have the ego get in the way
have that be dissolved enough
to where you can be receptive to really
good feedback
and incorporate that in
with nunchi also personal relations take
precedence over business
so success is by establishing
anti-fragile relationships based on
mutual
trust and benefit so koreans judge
individuals based on noonshee
so meaning that your
rapport building like we did in
especially chapters one through seven of
high level perception
where you noticed that we were very much
not as oriented by consciousness and
metaphysics until the very end
because we were building rapport with
people about what is very
common and ways to see in higher
resolution around
what's really common and so
when you build rapport you build the
personal relationship
first you prioritize that in building an
anti-fragile relationship
first and then everything else
especially in the business sense
will fall harmoniously in line
because you trust one another and you
understand that you're growing the pie
for one another
that it doesn't have something to do
with self-dealing
and ego
and so the business culture is grounded
in respectful rapport
doing things like checking with a mutual
friend to ensure peak nunchi in higher
clout cold
emails etc so things like i'm still
working on this myself but
things like when there
is a higher node
somebody with more clout status
to know how to navigate that
relationship is something that even for
the last couple of years that i've been
trying to figure out how to do
better and better and i have my good
moments with it
but there are also times when
i don't slow down enough to actually be
able to
analyze the scenario and potentially get
the perspective of one of my mentors
that might be
you know 35 or 40 years old that's been
there before
and learn from them on how to
optimize the navigation of that social
relationship
and then i don't have to fall on my face
in the learning process again
and so those sorts of rare candies or
level ups are really important and to
humble yourself to the extent to know
when to do that is really critical
and again spending time developing
fostering personal contacts particularly
the first meeting should be all about
simply establishing rapport and building
trust man that can't be emphasized
enough
we're getting a good amount of inquiries
from people around the world that are
trying to be like hey can i do
x y or z for simulation these different
components
and whenever the alignment
is really resonant when we feel the
first
call with the person it's all about
getting to know the person
at a deeper level getting to know their
god realization where they're at in
their spiritual journey where they're at
in their god expression
their god actualization their outward
journey
and seeing how much alignment is there
and then
figuring out some of the exploration on
a co-creation level on the business side
of things
and how we can help be a mirror on the
god realization side of things
and this is going to be really critical
for everybody
in their nunchi in their emotional
intelligence
is knowing how to prioritize building
rapport
and building trust and delaying their
gratification
and
there are also going to be times when
it's important to
just go with the flow artistically with
what is coming intuitively to do
and that that is perfection
the exact way that it's expressed is
perfection
through you again we talk about this so
much but at the most
non-dual level it all just simply is
perfect whole free already
unconditionally and at the dualistic
level on the dualistic concession
you have what is suffering and you have
well-being
and you want to navigate yourself more
and more towards well-being
it's already navigating you more and
more
towards well-being prosperity
abundance and to recognize that
at the level of the many at the level of
multiplicity at the level of
individuality
that we all are the same source we are
all the same infinite the same god
expressing itself here
in this reality in this dreamed creation
and that we are eternal
that this is just one expression
and that we've been doing these
expressions we're going to keep doing
these expressions
and so to know how to navigate that also
because when you give
kids and adults these three little
circles that have past
present and future written on them and
many people in the west will take
past present and future and line them up
linearly when asked to line them up
and many people in the east when they're
asked to line them up they'll stack the
past present and future
right on top of each other and that's
basically the essence of the synthesis
the grand synthesis between the east and
west
it's the synthesis of the inward the
infinite the eternal
with the outward individual
artistic expression of each of us
and nunchi emotional intelligence plays
a massive role in our success
our ability to be able to like a jedi
navigate the social relationships
navigate with high amounts of emotional
intelligence
to maximize our unique artistic
expressions potential it's as simple as
that
have that meta communicative analysis
be the sky that is experiencing the
clouds
and have a meta macro perspective
on how to undergo a process of
upgrading and augmenting your abilities
that's it nunchi subtle art and ability
to listen and engage
others moods i'm really grateful to
shaker pie
and josh holland for introducing me to
this concept
and i know saleem's also a big
proponent of this and even mariah as
well and it's just been fun to
learn from them and be able to take this
on
myself as well because i care so much
about emotional intelligence i care
so much about spirituality and how they
actually
help tremendously with everything that
we do in the outward expression
so to really be able to dive into this
you know when you walk into a house ask
the person should i take my shoes off
and if you're really spiritually
intelligent you will always take your
shoes off
because as the native americans here
said that
shoes kill your connection to the earth
so it's actually
better to always take your shoes off
when you're at the park
take your shoes off when you're at the
beach take your shoes off
feel your feet in the grass feel your
feet on the soil feel your feet in the
sand
similarly noon she is being
showered it's having good hygiene it's
having brushed your teeth
that way when you're talking to somebody
they don't have to
think about how you smell poorly
or you have bad breath
you never want to put that on somebody
else because technically you're putting
that on yourself
and you don't want to do that because
you wouldn't want that happening to you
you don't like it when people haven't
done well on their oral hygiene
it's really common sense it's nunchi is
very common sense
emotional intelligence is really common
sense
but we have to go through these
permutations we have to go through the
combinatorics
all of the different combinations and
algorithms of social expressions
we have to become aware of
the eyebrows of the jaw
of the wow
or the hole my gosh
to know how to navigate that is critical
to know
how to sit with somebody and build a
rapport
and build trust and how to know how to
surgically ask the right questions
i did a whole ted talk tedx sf talk
on the art of powerful questions on how
to do that
to be able to ask the right question
is the vast majority of the game in the
dream that we're in
to know surgically
with high emotional intelligence how to
drop the perfect question
in to show somebody like damn
that person asked a fantastic question
thanks for caring about me
and then they're like well my answer is
and then you're there
present with them and you're hitting
back another good ball
but then there also if they have high
noon xi high emotional intelligence
they'll hit you over a question
about your god realization or about your
god
actualization and your expression and
how they can be in service to you just
like how you're
aiming to be in service to them because
ultimately we're all in service to one
another
in this dreamed expression
it's as simple as that i love you so
much infinite love
infinite adoration thank you
i would love to hear how you feel about
nunchi how you feel about emotional
intelligence becoming a jedi
all of these nuances of interpersonal
dynamics
of all of the para language the meta
communication
based on also the nodes level of status
and clout
as well all of these nuances all these
variables would love to hear from you in
the comments
if the video brought you value like the
video please subscribe if you haven't
share the video with people that you
know this would profoundly positively
influence
and also you can join the channel and
become a member
all of the revenue goes directly back
into actualizing all the cool projects
that we have going on
and also you get great exclusive
benefits and
that is all thank you very much
give all of these metacognitive
meta communicative meta
awareness around eq
and social dynamics and nunchi
a deeper analysis and you'll be
surprised
at how much you will
ramp up your success
adore you thank you
you